what about the time you met michael
jackson
michael jackson well michael
we met michael in chicago at the regal
theater
him and his band had won a contest at
the high school
and the winner got
to open for
bobby taylor in the vancouvers and uh
jerry butler it was a double bill
or triple bill with the jackson five
and that was the first time we saw him
and
oh man it was like seeing
it was incredible here's this little guy
who's the littlest guy you ever saw
and he's he's acting like a
seasoned performer you know he's doing
all the dance steps
he was a big jackie wilson uh fan
so michael doing all the steps and then
they sang
my girl you know the temptations
and oh they were incredible and so and
we shared a dressing room
and so there we are michael used to get
a little
coca-cola car case you know turn it
upside down and
stand on it and stand in the mirror and
you know comb out his uh his little
little natural you know he's in there
he was a cool guy and bobby uh
you know bobby taylor who's
yeah we had a hit record and you know
that's why we were on motown
and uh bobby uh
he's the kind of guy you know hey come
on uh
come on to detroit that's what he told
the jackson five
and joe come on detroit you stay at my
place you know
we'll then we'll get you into motown
we'll okay with motown
they did yeah they did so uh
yeah yeah we knew michael before anybody
before barry gordy before anybody wow
wow that's cool you're like forced gum
your life like
weaves through all this all
thanks so much for watching this clip
and if you drink
coffee you need a mug shot mug
that's my first ever mug shot and this
mug is available on
amazon as well as at stevo.com so go
ahead and click the link in the
description below
this is what you're gonna find and grab
yourself a mug shot mug
yeah dude yeah
dude